should investors be free to choose how
much risk they wish to take well that is
not the case in hong kong as regulators
have just banned retail investors from
using complicated investment instruments
like crypto spot etfs crypto exchanges
will now need to test investors
knowledge before allowing them to trade
these assets this is very similar to how
the traditional financial market works
in the usa where you have to be an
accredited investor to access certain
financial instruments this can be
discriminatory and extremely unfair so
should investors be free to choose how
much risk they wish to take